if you're returning to the office this
summer you might be coming back to a
chilly welcome
office temperatures have long been a
common gripe among workers and might
have an impact on how productive they
are i think you'd be shocked to see how
many people take time out of their day
to try to adjust their environment so
that they can actually focus on their
work this is robert bean he's a fellow
and lecturer at ashrae an organization
that creates standards for things like
temperature and ventilation in buildings
he's also an expert on their standard
for creating a workplace climate which
is typically used by offices bean will
walk us through how the factors they
consider need to balance out to get the
climate just right and by throwing off
just one factor can leave your office
feeling like it's still stuck in winter
when we use air temperature as the sole
metric you know what's on the thermostat
on the wall as our sole proxy for
thermal comfort it's like saying baking
soda is a cake
we're missing all of the other
ingredients to figure out how to make a
space more comfortable ashrae looks at a
number of factors that can influence the
thermal climate
first environmental factors
air
measures how fast the air moves in a
space
while mean radiant temperature looks at
the average of the temperatures of
different surfaces
and things like air temperature and
humidity are also measured
if you think about your own day-to-day
lives and your thermal experience and
you feel drafts and you feel cold floors
and you feel the heat coming through the
window which is radiant temperature not
air temperature there's many many
ingredients environmental factors are
combined with two personal factors which
are a little more obvious one is
metabolic rate that's how fast your body
processes energy and you can be hotter
or colder depending on how much you move
the other is clothing insulation if
you're wearing light clothes you'll be
colder than someone wearing heavier
clothes and that's the challenge that we
have for you know indoor environmental
consultants is to really understand
these people what are they wearing what
are they doing
how long are they going to be there and
how does the environment around them
going to affect their
sensation and then ultimately their
perception but to get the personal and
environmental factors into balance
ashrae also considers local discomfort
factors which help determine the
specifics of what make people
uncomfortable we don't want to have
giraffes we don't want to have cold
floors right we don't want it to be so
dry or so humid they'll tell you what
you want but more importantly they'll
tell you what they don't want bean says
one source of discomfort is when
surfaces are different temperatures
which is called radiant asymmetry that's
what happens if you're sitting next to a
window and one arm gets warmer than the
other another is draft which mostly
affects the parts of your body that
aren't covered by clothes like that skin
on your ankle where your pants don't
quite meet your shoe
when that ankle is colder than say your
head that's called vertical air
temperature another factor ashrae tries
to measure we want to be able to create
a space using architecture enclosure
design interior design and mechanical
systems
to create these boundary conditions that
are diverse
but they allow people to experience the
space without stress
that's the end goal
so that's what ashrae takes into account
but if there's so much thought put into
your workplace climate then why can your
office still feel so cold
it's really like a domino effect so we
know that in buildings for example
that have a lot of glass the mean rating
temperature is going to go up because
the sunlight is heating up all that
glass so what people do is they crank
the air temperature down so they're
trying to balance that out
for many buildings overcompensating with
the ac might be the reason you feel too
cold a 2009 study of 95 office buildings
found that most set the thermostat
colder than guidelines suggest there
isn't an across-the-board reason the ac
gets turned too low but researchers from
center for the built environment say
that poorly designed or maintained units
could be part of the problem but beyond
the ac changes in any factor can make
you feel colder not moving around
sitting too close to a vent or wearing
clothes that are too light some studies
also suggest that thermostat settings
may be skewed toward men's preferences
who tend to wear longer heavier layers
in the office and can have a naturally
faster metabolic rate we know that it's
impossible to make everybody happy what
the standard can do when it's properly
applied is that we can
create conditions so that the majority
of people would be satisfied some
experts say that turning the thermostat
up a few degrees and allowing people to
adapt their spaces to suit their own
comfort is one solution to cold offices
as soon as you're able to adapt then
you'll be able to see that the
temperature doesn't need to be at such a
low value that it can allow to climb up
things like providing personal fans at
desks can allow buildings to keep the
office warmer without sacrificing
comfort an annual program in japan
loosens up dress codes so workers can
wear lighter clothes into the office to
help reduce the need for air
conditioning but if changing your office
thermostat isn't an option you can try
asking to move to a different seat you
might be more comfortable next to a
window where the radiant temperature is
warmer or in a spot with lower airflow
away from a vent
and if all else fails it's not a bad
idea to keep that extra sweater at your
desk